Hey, present. Good morning. How are you?
But.
Good morning, how are you?
I'm good. How's everything going on your end?
Uh, busy, but uh, you know...
One task at a time.
Is he?
Yes.
Friday is busy that too when there's a holiday upcoming.
Yep.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, I thought like it would be a lighter day, but it's opposite, I guess.
But.
It is in the grand scheme of things, you would say yes, it is slightly lighter if I compare it to Monday Tuesdays. Fridays usually are on a lighter side of things, but we still have a lot of things to still get done to get caught up on from the rest of the beginning of the week. So it still stays busy.
Yeah.
I.
Okay.
Oh, got it. Understood. Yeah, let me share my screen. I'm good. I'm good. Things are going good. So I work with Canada and US both, so I get caught up in holidays. So I am working on Monday and next Monday I would take it and off when US is off. So.
Kam, how are you?
Yeah.
Right.
That's when I will try and enjoy my holiday.
Nice.
Ah, okay. I see.
Yeah, yeah, let me share my screen and I'll show you the deck that we present with the concrete agenda. So we usually discuss last month's performance and based on that, the agenda is check-in, highlights, action tracker. If there are any introduce from previous meeting, KPI analysis, CSAT analysis, then way forward, upcoming events and recap.
All right.
Sure.
Yeah.
So Microsoft is performing good. His metrics are going in the right area. This second month and I already see the data is going the right direction. I talked to him, I spoke with him, he's happy working with it. Actually, he's saying he's learning A lot. So that's going in the right direction.
Kour.
Mm.
He is very appreciative of the support that he's getting and I see him on the team calls and everything and I see him participating. So that's something very good. So you tell how was his second month.
It's been good. I agree.
Performance is good, just going well, still in the same direction. Definitely, yeah, metrics and numbers and all of that is all in the in the in the place where it should be.
So I've been interacting with him a little bit too, and he seems to be in a good place in terms of what he's learning and picking up from the team and just the support he's getting from the guys around him as well. So that's, I can agree with that.
Oh, great, great to hear that. Moving on next, no to-dos from previous meeting. Performance analysis, his utilization for April was 100%, so that's going good. That means he's entering time correctly. No issues from that standpoint. Ticket closures 160.
Mm.
from second month, that's really good. 160 is a good number. CSAT, 97%, but we already spoke about DSAT that he received last month when we met. So he closed the ticket prematurely without user's consent.
Mhm.
Yeah.
And we already discussed that with him. I explained him like in F12, not only in IST Athena, but in across F12. The thing is, we need to confirm with the customer that the things are going right and that they are giving options to resolve the ticket, but overall.
Service count is 38 surveys, so that is good. That's really a good number. 38 surveys is really high. Coming on to attendance, yeah, we do track the attendance and we see how the attendance is going so that we are able to see whether they are planned and planned. And we do this for all F2 folks. So this is something which is.
Yeah.
Kour.
non-negotiable, we do track it on daily basis.
Yeah.
Okay, moving on next way forward. So that's the last slide that we have, but we'll continue working with Marcos, although I know he is self-sufficient, he will do, but I'll keep coaching him if anything required or if he needs any help in understanding a few things. So I'll keep coaching him and make sure that he's consistent.
Mm.
Wonderful. That is great. In terms of time off, he has requested for some time off. I think next week is the dates. From Monday to Friday, he's got the trip that he has to take there. So that's been approved. So we.
I get.
Just wanted to let you know that he's he has requested for time off for next week, so that should be fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I saw your email as well and thanks for approving. So.
I'll make sure that from going forward I'll talk to him like at least two weeks notice in advance is given so that we are so everything is planned.
Yeah.
Okay, wonderful. That is everything from my end. I think I'm pretty happy with him, so I don't have complaints.
Okay.
That's the best thing I would like to hear going on a Friday weekend in a chill factor now.
That's right, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Thanks for the honest and open feedback. We really appreciate the present and we really appreciate our partnership with your team.
Certainly, we appreciate yours too. Hopefully, you have a wonderful weekend.
YouTube.
OKOK, have a good day. Bye.
Thanks. Have a great day. You too. Bye.